memory is everything
without it we are blind
[Music]
without it we lead the plate of our
world to chance
[Music]
i'm sorry to disturb you thomas but i've
just received troubling news tell me
what is it it's grindelwald
her time is closed my brothers and
sisters our world with the michaels
begins
today
the world as we know it is coming undone
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me mr kowalski we
need you said it wanted out on a one out
you do know i'm a witch right
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
this is the team that's gonna take down
the most dangerous visit in a century
who wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
oh
no one can know everything
not even you
what are you doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
dangerous times
favor dangerous men
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
mr kowalski my pleasure
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind
[Music]
we'll use that we could reshape the
world even if we make mistakes
we can't try to make things right
[Music]
we're gonna need some
[Music]
help there's nothing you can do to stop
me
[Music]
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
i trust you're enjoying your wand mr
kowalski
can i keep this
[Music]
[Music]
you